anyone familiar with the hit series
lucifer knows that it's chock full of
memorable moments and scenes
from a crook who gets caught with his
pants down to a detective turned into a
human smoothie keep watching to find out
about these moments and more
despite season one's darker tone there
is still some solid humor to be found
with many solid exchanges and insults
one of the more entertaining moments is
a glorious exchange between lucifer and
chloe in the show's inaugural episode
lucifer's extended vacation on earth is
interrupted when a famous friend of his
is killed in a drive-by shooting the
subsequent police investigation lands
him in the crosshairs of detective chloe
decker with whom he tries to solve the
murder their partnership is at first
very one-sided with lucifer skirting
various legalities to interrogate people
including dangling a rapper out of a
window it's after this near act of
homicide that one of the rapper's
entourage points out chloe's former life
as an actor lucifer is quick to jump on
this and praise chloe's assets in a
movie titled hot tub high school the one
with the famous nude scene coming out
the hot tub it was like a complete fast
times rip-off she was like the new
phoebe kate she quickly asserts her
authority by slapping cuffs on him for
his actions much to lucifer's sadistic
delight
with the broader comedic set pieces of
later seasons it's fun to look back on
simpler exchanges like this one it's an
early taste of the frequently recurring
dynamic that would make the devil and
cop duo so likable
we are first shown a taste of lucifer's
backstory in season one when amidst an
investigation chloe sees lucifer's scars
now
you can't argue with that can you it's a
low-key but very effective moment where
lucifer doesn't sugarcoat the actual
truth stating bluntly that the scars are
left over from where he cut off his
wings in defiance of his father your dad
did that to you no no no that's where i
cut my wings off
what well i didn't amazed it i told her
to chloe not yet a believer in lucifer's
demonic status doesn't truly grasp the
truth behind his scars she looks upon
them with what appears to be genuine
shock and legitimate sympathy and she
quickly stops when lucifer asks her not
to touch them the interactions between
lucifer and amena deal are always a
persistent source of drama throughout
the entire series
their often strained relationship would
grow from a heated rivalry rife with
deceptions to a healthy and mature
familial bond during the show's first
season we would get a taste of this
kinder relationship in the episode
wingman
lucifer's prized possession his wings
had been stolen and he'd made it his
mission to get them back
after determining that a piece of
divinity let loose on earth would spell
disaster a menadil begrudgingly agrees
to help this leads them to an
underground auction where the wings are
listed as a high priced item amongst
other alleged divine relics during the
bid for the first item the chains of
saint paul the brothers would share a
brief moment of camaraderie
paul's roots were too thick to fit in
those champions i know that man never
could pass on dessert could he he should
have been the saint of funny cakes
[Laughter]
they not only point them out as fake but
take time to dunk on saint paul's
inability to pass on dessert sharing a
laugh before resuming their respectively
combative tones this is undercut later
by the revelation that amena deal played
a role in the wing's theft however it's
a legitimately sweet moment and a
precursor to the emotional growth both
characters would soon make
father frank was a one-shot character
who definitely left a major impact on
lucifer and the show's fandom
in the season 1 episode a priest walks
into a bar the streetwise priest comes
to lucifer looking for a favor
he asks lucifer to help him with conor
an orphaned youth who frank saw fit to
take under his wing lucifer being
repellent to anyone who serves his
father is initially callous to frank
this would change when frank under
lucifer and chloe's protection shares
his backstory as a traveling musician
frank's life changed after a car
accident killed not only conor's parents
but frank's daughter as well
after this sobering revelation lucifer
feels intrigued by frank's claim of
being a superior piano player and
demands to see him in action the duo
then engages in a competitive but
friendly piano duet and genuinely seems
content in each other's company oh i
think i know what you mean
something like that yeah chloe upon
returning sees the two playing together
and smiles as she sees lucifer actually
connecting with someone this newfound
friendship would be cut short by frank's
untimely death something that lucifer
responds to with furious anger
despite only making one on-screen
appearance frank plays a major role in
lucifer finding his humanity and growing
as a person
the season 1 finale of lucifer
definitely ends the show's story arc
with a fittingly large bang malcolm a
recently resurrected dirty cop looks to
reclaim his money by holding trixie
chloe's daughter hostage
it's a situation made all the dire
because of lucifer's newfound mortality
something malcolm takes full advantage
of lucifer attempts to draw on malcolm's
desires but the latter reveals that his
true desire is to see lucifer die
with a bullet in his stomach all seems
lost for the former ruler of hell until
in a moment of desperation he turns to
someone unexpected god lucifer makes a
plea to his father that he'll finally do
his bidding if god protects chloe
[Music]
his father hears the message and
restores lucifer to his full strength
it's a wonderfully directed moment only
enhanced by tom ellis's performance
it may be a smaller scale victory
especially when compared to the larger
multi-character battles in future
finales but it serves as the perfect
book end for season one and sets up
intriguing plot developments for season
two
added to the cast in season two is
lucifer's mother who after escaping hell
inhabits the body of the recently
deceased charlotte richards
upon arriving on earth charlotte goes
about making things complicated for
lucifer and chloe and their budding
relationship from nearly blowing up
chloe with a car bomb to almost blasting
linda with her celestial energy
charlotte's arrival is marked by rampant
insanity one moment that shouldn't be
forgotten is a devious stunt she pulled
on the perpetually gullible dan espinoza
while leaning into her life as charlotte
richards the goddess of creation begins
a fling with the hapless detective which
leads to a very steamy public kiss in
front of several restaurant patrons
including amena deal her other son
amenities sorrow is punctuated by a
giddy maze taking pictures of his
reaction
this moment as well as their entire love
affair would of course have
repercussions later on for dan
trixie may never get much to do on her
own but she still has a wonderful
chemistry with others a sizable amount
of mace's character development has a
lot to do with her relationship with
trixie which is similar to that of what
an aunt might have with her niece
many of the most riveting scenes of the
show have trixie somewhere in the
crosshairs of that season's danger any
time we get to see lucifer interact with
trixie it is a guaranteed source of
charm and hilarity from traumatizing her
schoolyard bully with his devil face to
buying her a doll lucifer has certainly
given her an interesting childhood
the swear jar joke though a remarkably
simple one always elicits sizable laughs
lucifer discovers that trixie must put
money in a jar for chloe every time she
uses foul language
swagger oh yes trixies
you give your child money every time she
swears oh bravo detective in response to
this revelation lucifer tries to give
her a crisp 20 bill to spend on ample
curse words later on chloe reprimands
him for teaching trixie loophole curse
words to skirt around the swear jar
stipulation
well she called her math homework a
cluster duck and her teacher a mother
flunker it's a hilarious moment and
another key factor in lucifer's ever
growing appreciation for humanity
it would take a long time before mays
would finally find a partner that could
match her spontaneity and dubious
morality by the end of the final season
that partner would reveal themselves to
be eve the first woman however before
mays was chasing dangerous bounties into
the sunset with eve there was a road not
taken in season three she would seek a
change of pace to her now very cyclical
work-life balance in order to shake
things up she opts to chase a bounty by
the name of ben rivers to canada ben
quickly proves himself to be just as
crafty as mays making for a very playful
chase between them ben eventually
explains that his status as a serial
killer is false and that he had been
framed mays agrees to help him and with
the help of her friends in los angeles
is able to clear his name before he goes
off into the night ben offers maze the
opportunity to come with him
what if you came with me
we can do this mace
you and me we're the same
no roots
no family
maize considers it but ultimately
chooses her life in la over a future
with ben their goodbye is definitely a
meaningful moment but an important part
of her growth
when lucifer moved to netflix for its
fourth year series creators definitely
took advantage of their newfound lack of
restrictions
after rekindling his relationship with
the free-spirited eve lucifer's regained
streak of debauchery leaks into his life
at work
one notable moment inspired an episode
title after lucifer wears his quote orgy
pants to work
for many one glimpse of lucifer's rear
end would be enough but the episode saw
fit to up the ante
while on the case of a recent victim
chloe and lucifer's investigation leads
them to a nudist colony in order to
enter the mustache robe a stipulation
that chloe protests but lucifer and ella
quickly embrace with gusto
lucifer a wedding round detective season
4 is where the show really starts
leaning heavily into its comedic
elements and this is a prime example of
that shift it's an underrated yet
hysterical little moment that showcases
the show's vibrant and often madcap new
creative direction
if lucifer fans were only allowed to
make a gif out of just one moment from
the show we'd like to make a case for
this one when the show's fifth season
dropped the cast was joined by state
farm spokesman dennis haysberg as
lucifer's dad god himself god being
all-knowing already felt familiar with
the show's core characters including
poor dan
dan upon realizing just who he's talking
to starts behaving strangely to humorous
effect
mr
god
listen um
i'm sorry that i slept with your wife i
didn't know she was married at the time
i swear to god at first seems very laid
back about the situation but then
quickly showcases his true feelings on
the matter by exploding dan into a human
smoothie that paints the walls much to
lucifer's shock god very quickly
reverses the event and puts dan back
together but leaves the poor detective
frazzled and traumatized a rare show of
anger from god during his tenure as a
supporting character but a morbid and
hilarious one
it's fair to say that lucifer leaned
heavily into its comedic elements after
the show switched from fox to netflix
gone was the darker noir aesthetic of
the early seasons and in its place were
comedy and bright colors the show's
final season definitely doubles down on
comedic moments with one serving as its
ultimate crescendo
with things amiss in heaven lucifer
plans to see what the problem is but
unfortunately he can't get his wings to
work lucifer also discovers that linda
has been compiling all her data on him
in order to pen a tell-all book
the group decides to cull through this
data in order to pinpoint what's going
on with lucifer's wings and hilarity
naturally ensues the most gut-busting
moment is linda's very direct
interpretation of the gang's day-to-day
interactions it's a sequence that feels
like someone made a bot watch every
episode of the series then write a
script crazy that the killer was the
first person we met
what are the chances i know it's a scene
run totally on autopilot with every
character's identifiable or quirky trait
maxed out to 11 complete with a
comically stock back and forth lucifer
and chloe and maze cartoonishly pulling
a severed human head out of a bag it's a
truly wonderful moment and a hilarious
summation of why fans love these
characters so much
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
lucifer are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]